abandon ego
selflessness will lead to harmony
strike with honor
this is my destiny
[Music]
i'm good i'm good how are you doing
i'm great thanks for asking i love the
jacket you have on it reminds me of
like the jacket that you're wearing in
the movie as well all right yeah well
this is like gifted to me by a friend
uh leno yeah it's a japanese design and
i love that
it's really good you look cool with your
hood and stuff it's like you're kind of
dark and beautiful is that the snake ice
thing oh you know what i can be snake
eyes i can be the baroness that can be
whatever you want andrew okay okay yeah
yeah let's put them all together
yes
i feel like uh snake eyes to a certain
extent is like an origin story for storm
shadow as well so what was it like
stepping into the role were there any
pressures as an actor any job any role
you take on is pressure because you just
want to do your best and you know i
think uh with this there's the uh added
thing of of of fans the fans the you
know and i think to do that uh to do
them justice so we spoke i spoke to a
lot of fans while uh before we filmed
and
trying to find out who he is his soul is
in in his essence so
um
i don't know the pressure is another
thing but the the work is the main thing
and once if you just focus on the work
and really doing a good job that
pressure
is alleviated uh for i think yeah but if
you're in good hands as well with the
the robert as well our director
makes a lot of sense now i know that the
brotherhood bond between snake eyes and
tommy is something that's really central
to their characters we see that in the
comics we see that in the movie as well
so what was it like working with henry
golding what's the dynamic like it's
interesting
him and i uh we grew up in the same part
of the world and uh but we're also so
we've got similarities but a lot of
differences too
um and i think that's just something
that you know um
but then once you're working together
you're working together and i think the
the uh we have to figure that out and my
avenue is storm shadow in his avenues uh
a snake eyes and just meeting in the
middle trying to collaborate figure out
how to do this and how to do that that
was
good in a way for us to to to play off
each other uh it kind of fed into it
now i know that the movie ends with a
very special scene of tommy asking the
baroness to call him storm shadow that
was that was a big moment for us
watching in the cinema so can you share
what's in store for your character's
future when once he joins cobra and i
think that's it's almost the beginning
of his his journey as as becoming storm
center so yeah i i think i don't know
i'd love to to know what larry has in
mind what the fans would want to see
all these things that would take uh take
into consideration make him as
three-dimensional as possible and is
interesting that's the main thing i
think his upbringing is very interesting
um you know someone who
was born into this this code and this uh
honor and um lineage
uh and history and then the fact that
he's broken away from that i think it'd
be cool he could kind of do i don't know
if my filmmaker brain i'd be you know
doing flashbacks comparing the past
tommy to the tommy that he is uh
the storm shadow that he becomes you
know
uh
then i'd do his bow and arrow as well
because he we've never seen him with
this bow and arrow and that's one of his
signature weapons yeah yeah i mean have
you have you considered taking up
archery just to try it out for fun
yeah i do archery just for me you know
just for a skill that i'd want to do
whether or not you know
it happens in this and if i can use it
great but yeah archery i think is such a
cool skill
yeah totally you know i feel like that's
all the time i have with you today i had
such a great time thank you for spending
the time with me i hope you have a
wonderful day ahead you too you too
thank you very much yeah
yeah
let me make something clear
cobra will be invincible
thank you you too
how are you today i'm good thank you for
asking how are you i'm perfect thank you
the baroness wow she's a very powerful
smart manipulative badass woman so what
about her made you want to take on the
role
yeah it was amazing as you said you know
she's a very powerful woman so i had a
great time it was all about you know her
power and
about not losing her sense of humor
which i think is something very
important
from her right
yeah she's bad but she's always
having fun she's always having fun
always in power that's why that's what i
love about her um but i do notice that
like throughout the movie she kind of
like switches her loyalties quite a bit
from like working with kendall to little
seeing her alongside scarlett so what is
her moral compass based off how do you
channel that that was um
well i think it makes sense because
she's capable of anything to get what
she wants so if kentucky is not doing
well anymore bye bye kenta
i like anta
now i know that most fans know you as
tokyo from money heist so what's it like
jumping from like an insanely popular
netflix series to another fan favorite
franchise like jijo it's been such an
adventure everything has been crazy
these last
two years of my life
a lot of things happened
and
i just can't say that i feel honored i
feel grateful
and
i'm taking advantage of everything
about the world is giving you know so
i feel
super happy
and i love my job so
that's good i think it's really
important to love your job you have a
really cool job
have a vocation right
yeah
now after watching the movie i feel like
i feel like there was so much more that
i wanted to see from the baroness like i
feel like she's just so cool i want to
see more of her so you know what are
some goals and expectations you have
with the character moving forward
can you imagine
a movie with awareness that would be
amazing right how would you want that to
go you never know you never know i would
be honored to do it
because she's a she's she's very funny
to play
i enjoyed it so hard
i had this huge conversation with robert
about how the baroness should be and we
were agree about the fact that she's
a badass and
so she's all she's allowed to do
everything
no rules you know no rules yeah so if i
would have the chance to
do an entire movie with the baroness
that would be amazing
let's see who knows who knows i've i got
my red lipstick on because of the
fairness so if there's a fairness movie
i'll be there i'll be there wow come on
love it
let's go let's go thank you thank you
thank you i think this is all the time i
have with you i know
if your heart is pure
our secrets will reveal themselves to
you
if not
they'll be your end
hi i'm sabina from geek culture in
singapore
um hi haruka how are you i'm very well
thank you how are you
i'm great thanks for asking i love the
red lipstick it's very bold
i recently watched the movie and you
know i find akiko such
a complex character she's this
mysterious woman i can't put my finger
on it but i like her um
what about her drew you to the role
um like i said she is a very complex
character i think she has a lot of like
layers she's not just
this like
you know token female fighter um
who's just like there to like do some
cool fighting you know she she actually
had because i think everyone in the film
are very late because it's such a
character-driven film so yeah that
that's something that really drew me to
the character for sure now are there any
similarities between your character and
yourself like were there any challenges
between this role too
well um i think akiko is a very loyal
person who's very protective of
things and people that she cares about i
have that quality i think i'm very i can
be very protective
of you know it being like a bit
overbearing um so i can i could
definitely relate that you know relates
to her in that sense um her like being a
total badass who can like
you know handle these weapons and do all
these like
fights that was a bit of a challenge
because you know while i've done some
like martial arts like boxing and stuff
fighting with these weapons was a
completely new experience to me so i had
a lot of training but um i really
enjoyed it so
yeah i'm actually really glad you
brought those fighting things up because
she has some incredible scenes like the
salt fights and the the motorcycle
scenes those are my personal favorite um
so you said that you had to do a bit of
training what was training like what was
preparation like so we had this
most incredible stunt team um lovely
stunt team who are our senseis so they
trained all the actors um two months
before we started filming
so we would train with them for four
hours every day for two months that was
our daily routine and then i'd go home
with my practice weapons um the softer
the padded weapons and go straight to
the gym and practice on my own for
another couple of hours um on a daily
basis
because you know i really want to do the
character justice and that's you know
being a skilled fighter isn't something
you can
fake really so i have to
put a lot of effort in do the cats
justice i think you definitely did akiko
justice
tomi snake guys and akiko have a very
interesting dynamic like you said akiko
is fiercely loyal she's super protective
but you can see she's also really
suspicious of tommy and say guys so
what was it like working with andrew uh
andre koji and henry golding and how did
the three of you go about creating this
this really intense but really
interesting dynamic together
well um henry is
an absolute dream to work with he is the
loveless human being
who is so warm and and gracious and
down-to-earth such a great guy on top of
the fact that he's such a talented actor
is like fully committed to the role so
it was very inspiring to to work with
him you know so i think the dynamic just
came very
organically because my reaction came
very naturally um and i think because
akiko has this you know interesting
complex relationship with snake eyes
because yes on one hand she's very
suspicious of him but also she's kind of
intrigued by him at the same time
because she kind of sees
um
something in him that reminds her of
herself and her past as well
um so that was really fun to play
andrew koji i've actually known him for
like
10 years or so because we're both
london-based actors so i had actually
worked with him a handful of times
before snake eyes and so when i first
got the offer
for the role he was the one i messaged
first going hey andrew guess what i'm
coming to uh
to join you guys and so that was really
fun um being able to work with him again
thank you thank you so much i think
that's all the time i have but i had a
really lovely time thank you for
answering my questions thank you i hope
you have a lovely day ahead thank you so
much you too
bye
you